hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel what today i have the uh
tremendous pleasure of unboxing the near
replicant collector's edition this is
actually specifically the white
snow edition square enix did send me
this i have to thank them tremendously
for that um but for anyone who doesn't
already know i was such a big fan of nia
i actually hosted the official
panel that they had at pax i love
yokotaro i have a
signed signature for him on my fridge
such a big fan but i actually never
played the original near
and near replicant for anyone who
doesn't know is effectively a remake of
that so for me this is like this
incredibly exciting world that i can't
wait to dive into
um so i thought that today we would
unbox the white snow edition but i also
wanted to let you all know that i'm
going to be streaming the game tonight
probably do an hour on youtube and then
the rest on twitch and uh because i've
been
trying to raise 50 000 for ablegamers
which is a charity organization that
raises money for disabled gamers
i will be giving away a whole bunch of
codes so when i've actually figured out
what time that will be i would guess
probably like
7 30 p.m pacific time or so
i will let you all know so that you can
win copies of the game and experience
this all with me but for right now
let's open this beautiful box uh
i mean the outside from the front this
this incredible
and extremely iconic artwork
right from the top um makes it real hard
to try to throw out boxes which is
something that i generally really do try
to do because
boy do they take up space but we're
gonna start
opening it up oh boy
okay here we go
we do have some cautions on the back cut
hasn't product has functional sharp
points not intended for children under
15 years not a toy handled with care
actual products may differ slightly in
appearance to images shown
then we have a sleeve here that we are
going to
[Music]
well you've all now seen more than i
have
this is lovely it has this um i mean
obviously the box is very white it is
the white snow edition that is clearly
the theme
these beautiful lilies on the front
this this is this is lovely this is very
very very nice
really nice design it uh says in the
writing on the ridges
again near replicant white snow edition
i think what we're gonna do is flip it
right here
and then lift it but i'm gonna bring the
camera a little bit closer
before we do that okay let's do it
oh man so starting with
um worth noting this does not actually
come with a copy of the game
uh i got that separately this is
oh boy the steel case
for the game near replicant version
point two point two point four point
seven point four point four point eight
point seven point one point three point
nine dot dot dot
um naturally is completely empty
but this is a really nice steel book
for sure we also have
this is beautiful this design is so nice
oh man okay i'll show you guys this
private open it
again everything's very shiny
this is a super intricate design on the
front here back
similarly kind of looks like a mirror
let me open her up this is
the soundtrack i guess we'll go actually
piece by piece so this first part says
whis edition in game i believe it's
actually pronounced a
vice part one another edit version it's
got
uh all of your composers listed in here
and then two
is a second edition arrangement oh and
there are quotes from yokotaro in here
as well anokabe
that's really cool again as someone who
wrote
a panel full of jokes for a pax with
yokotaro
and okabe um it was tons of fun they
genuinely do have the senses of humor
that any
near fans will like kind of recognize
they are truly wonderful people
that i absolutely love basically it goes
on to explain
the another edit version which sounds
like it was very driven by yoko which is
super cool
and then we have uh you know okabe
listed as the producer
and a composer obviously as well as a
number of others so
it's very collaborative effort so it
looks like so that's what this book is
about
and then yeah this this little folder
here contains
part one and part two of the soundtrack
again beautiful presentation how lovely
you know this whole thing is just
so nice so neat okay next up
we have white snow edition i think these
are pins actually
um for anyone who watched my
um the basically reaction video hello
of the uh press conference they did
at tokyo game show a while ago
um i believe it included a lot of these
details so
if we open this up
huh
these are very nice
very nice and they also have these
little
thumb holes in the phone which a lot of
collectors editions just absolutely
don't do
so you can pull them out and yeah i was
correct these are all uh
basically books that on the back
are pins with just tons and tons and
tons of detail in here
these are absolutely lovely this is like
for me when i watched that conference
these three i think were the things that
um made me really really want this
edition
um alongside of course the absolutely
beautiful statue from prime one which
really blew my mind and broke my heart
because it's very expensive and very big
but um i think these pins are just
absolutely stunning really really nice
um
so much of the intricate detail that
we've come to know and love
from platinum games you know what i'm
saying okay
next up i'm flipping around for you
oh we have oh these didn't go anywhere
near as deep as i expected
this is very exciting to me hang on let
me rearrange the camera again
okay so our last piece here
um which is like exceptionally exciting
to me as someone who
just almost exactly six months ago
started working in
aaa game development as a writer these
are script collections
every time a studio releases anything
like this i'm so excited to
read them to get to learn from them i
will scour these i will take notes
for anyone who's interested in getting
into the industry in a writing capacity
that's a lot of what i've done every
step of the way is read as many scripts
as i could have to like get prepared
um over a span of years so whenever it
happens i feel like it's just so
valuable and this is a beautiful
presentation
again these boxes are absolutely
wonderful and also i'm sorry i keep
moving away from the microphone but
you know we have limitations here just
another very shiny
silvery box says script collection near
replicant on the side here
some more flowery designs on the back
and obviously all your books here it is
near replicant english voiceover script
english voiceover script
subquests two this one's real beefy
english voiceover script subquests one
english voiceover script main b
after two english voiceover script main
be after one
english voiceover script main a before
two and english voiceover script main a
before one
which to me makes perfect sense to
anyone who's not played nia before
probably sounds like garbage
[Laughter]
but let me open oh my god it's already
really nice art
[Music]
okay here's the first one this one is
english voiceover script
other just this beautiful kind of uh
gray really weathered looking paper
like a really weathered kind of
paperback setup here
that i think just looks so nice um got
some anime titties on the front there
which
you know you love to see it and then the
book itself
drowning lines it's not uh formatted
like a screenplay
exactly but not terribly far off they've
got
processing effects they've got generic
radio voices
there is a lot of text in here we've got
a meal in here
so i'm gonna have a wonderful time
reading through these this is a thing
that again i think is so cool when
writers are willing to share this stuff
it's so
like useful to learn from especially
with games where you really love the
writing
um when they release the book for
the insomniac spider-man game because
that's you can get that in hardcover you
can get that whole script it's
like i scoured it it's fantastic um
okay let me show you the rest of them
before we move on though let me just
bring you closer again
so we have a book number two
this is subquest one this is the
thickest
a lot going on here for sure this is
voiceover script
main b after two this is main b
after one
very nice english voiceover script main
a before
two and
near applicant english voice server
script main a before one
absolutely beautiful and that's actually
everything out of our box so these are
all of our books here
i'm gonna just put them right back in
here
these are again the things that made me
especially excited about this edition
for sure this is the box that contains
our pins
like a really uniform collector's
edition where even all of the boxes that
contain everything is just
like this stuff is just so so pretty
this is our soundtracks and this is
of course the near replicant
steel case and that's everything out of
the box
beautiful of course as i mentioned uh
the game isn't included um but for
people who did get this edition which i
believe is already sold out of course
the game is out
today they would have gotten a code
distributed digitally by
email um for steam i believe or via a
square enix account otherwise people who
pre-ordered also got wallpapers
and a digital version of one of the
soundtracks i believe one cool thing
that they did note
about the pens is that they should all
have enough weight
to stand up on their own which again as
someone who like loves statues and
collectibles
is actually not that easy i have a lot
of collectibles that are even like
actually full articulated figures that
can't stand up on their own so i kind of
wanted to put this to the test
nope it does
[Laughter]
yeah yep they certainly do which means
you don't have to use them as pins they
aren't useless things that just have to
sit
in this box which as a collector i love
i always judge things when they have to
have a base
to hold them up i way prefer a figure
that can just stand up by itself
obviously these are books slash pins
they are much smaller
um but the fact that they really do even
on this like terribly balanced little
fortress i've made here for the
collector's edition
are still actually uh standing up
together
beautiful i love that and i think that
that is pretty much it
everyone um like i said i've not
previously played
uh neoreplicant um it was previously
only released in japan
so i am extremely excited um i will
probably
stream the first hour here on youtube
i'll leave the vod up if you want to
catch it and then i'll jump over to
twitch
where we'll do another charity stream
where i will give away a bunch of codes
i have them for every platform
being xbox playstation and pc if you
want to jump on that um i hope to see
you then i'm really excited about this
game let's do it
thank you all for watching i will see
you guys next time bye